في حد
عا اسبوع رابع من حرب اسرائيل على قطاع
غزه لم تغب اصوات القنابل والصواريخ ومعها
انين الكاله وصرخات الفاقدين
ردن غزه خلال سبعه ايام اكثر من 1700 شهيد
ليرتفع العدد الاجمالي الى
8795 شهيدا منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي وكالعاده كان نحو ثلثي
الضحايا من الاطفال والنساء حسبي الله
واند ونعم الوكيل على حكام العرب اللي
شايفين
المنا
اسبوع شهد حراكا دوليا بدا اكثر جديه
تصريحات للامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو اثارت غضب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الذي طالب بالاعتذار عنها او
الاستقاله
وعلى مستوى اوسع اصدرت الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قرارا غير ملزم يؤيد
بالاكثر الساحقه وقف اطلاق النار في غزه
لاسباب انسانيه ويحث على وصول المساعدات
الى القطاع المحاصر وحمايه المدنيين وذلك
بعد اخفاق مجلس الامن في اتخاذ اجراء في
الاسابيع السابقه تحرك ازعج اسرائيل
العا ددت القر بانها دول
[موسيقى]
دنئ ضربه دبلوماسيه للاحتلال اعلنت
بوليفيا قطع علاقاتها مع اسرائيل وسحبت
تشيلي وكولومبيا سفير ايهما من تل ابيب
تنديدا بالعدوان على غزه ودعت جنوب
افريقيا الامم المتحده الى نشر قوه دوليه
لحمايه المدنيين في القطاع وفيما عد ضحضاح
الامريكي في عدد الضحايا اكدت الامم
المتحده صحه اعداد الشهداء التي اعلنتها
وزاره الصحه في غزه استنادا الى وثيقه من
22 صفحه تضم اسماء الشهداء وارقام طاقاتهم
[موسيقى]
الشخصيه شعبيا خرج الملايين في العالم في
تظاهرات عارمه تنديدا باستمرار العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه وبالمواقف الغربيه
الرسميه الداعمه لهذا العدوان اكبر
التجمعات كان في مدينه اسطنبول حيث قدرت
السلطات التركيه عدد المتظاهرين بمئات
الالاف وعلى ارض غزه ت الحرب الاسرائيليه
منحا اكثر دمويه بقطع الاتصالات والانترنت
يومين متواصلين ثم اطلاق اعنف حمله قصف
منذ بدء الحرب اصاب القصف مستشفى الاورام
الوحيد في القطاع ثم حدثت مجزره مروعه في
مخيم جباليا باستهداف تجمع وحدات سكنيه
بست قنابل تزين الواحده منها طنا من
المتفجرات في هجوم اوقع 400 شهيد وجريح
بينهم 18 شخصا من اسره مهندس البث بمكتب
الجزيره في غزه الزميل محمد ابو القمصان
تصعد العنف الاسرائيلي في جباليا جاء بعد
نكسات متتاليه مني بها الاحتلال على اكثر
من صعيد فبعد نشر كتائب القسام فيديو يظهر
ثلاث محتجزات اسرائيليات يوجهن انتقادات
حاده الى رئيس الوزراء
بن
[تصفيق]
امت الاعلام الاسرائيليه كلها عن بث
الفيديو امتثالا لتعليمات عسكريه وما هي
الا ساعات حتى اعلن الاحتلال تحرير
المجنده اوري مداش خلال عمليه بريه اعلان
وصفته حركه حماس بانه مزاعم لا صحه لها
والهدف منها التشويش على فيديو الاسيرات
الذي صدم المجتمع الاسرائيلي وفي ميدان
المعارك تعرض الاحتلال لاكبر خساره عسكريه
بعد السابع من اكتوبر اذ اقر الاعلام
العبري بقتل 17 جنديا من لواء جع فاتي في
اشتباكات منفصله وهجوم صاروخي مضاد
للدبابات في غزه ليرتفع بذلك العدد المعلم
للجنود القتله الى
335 منذ بدء الحرب بثت القسام مقاطع جديده
تظهر استهداف قوه راجله بقنبله محموله على
طائره مسيره في هجوم اسفر عن سقوط بعض
القتله نفذت الكتائب ايضا ثالث هجماتها
على قاعده اراز شمال قطاع غزه وقالت ان
مقاتليها قتلوا ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين من
المسافه
صفر وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رما يلا
دخل على خط الحرب لاول مره جماعه الحوثيين
في اليمن معلنه تنفيذ ثلاث هجمات بصواريخ
بالستيه ومسيرات على اهداف اسرائيليه وعلى
هامش الحرب الداميه حدث اختراق في ملف
المفاوضات الانسانيه ونجحت وساطه قطريه في
فتح معبر رفح لاول مره لخروج 81 جريحا
ونحو 400 شخص من الجنسيات الاجنبيه الى
خارج القطاع لاول مره منذ بدء العدوان
هيهم اطفال قاعدين في اكياس من عبيهم
اكياس بنحط فيهم يا عمي في
اكياس